ça c'est le gaz ça c'est très fort même
pas tu as gagné une voiture âgée de dix
mille euros
faut que je te vois que tu es
complètement moi la vraie ruche j'ai
trouvé par terre j'ai ramassé les
versants comme grande question c'est
d'abord ça fait 150 g c'est un peu plus
grand qu'un iphone et un iphone ça pèse
130 grammes
je suis noir et si le poème dont il est
question j'ai appris mais j'oublie tu
prends tes affaires tu vas chez là c'est
fait soit tu restes pas que le contrat
et tout va bien
soit tu risque l'exclusion définitive
quand reverra gélase crime et la
cheminée cheminée quoi cheminée mataji
chemine et eu d'écho chez les ch'tis il
faut dire chez unis s'ils ne s'en fait
pas du spi
c'est quoi cette machine c'est une
occasion en or les passeurs d'usiné tout
le dépôt
tu joue avec le feu dame 1
je tiens un truc c'est un internat
pour être une vraie chance pour toi
tu vois quoi lors du bâtard si je vous
éclater à servel car je commence par le
tea
tu vois quand tu leur je te maîtresses